can we go into some of the more
technical parts of selling the book yeah
so basically once you go on submission
and this is applying to having an agent
and approaching traditional publishing
houses you know your agent is going to
be sending your book to different
editors that they've identified that
they think the book could be appropriate
for so then it's kind of a lot of hurry
up and wait like the book goes out you
know and then maybe you're lucky in your
book sells at auction for a bazillion
dollars and you're set but for most
books it's going to take a number of
months for those editors who are getting
so many submissions to even get back to
you and then also it's not when I first
went into it I was like oh it's whether
or not they you know you wrote a great
book that is not what has to do with
whether your book sells writing a great
book is what gets you through those door
steps and gets you agent it like you've
gone through the hurdles you wrote a
great book but now it's a business so
it's about you know what is that
publishing house looking for for their
list what do they think is selling what
do they think they can mark it and that
has nothing to do with the quality of
your book that has everything to do with
the business which you can't predict or
control so once that process happens
ideally you're gonna get an offer or
multiple offers and you're gonna sell
your book so once that happens in my
case I had a three book deal for the
series so you have deadlines for the
subsequent books and then you basically
send off your manuscript that manuscript
goes to your editor your editor then is
going to go through a revision process
with you in my case I did not have to do
a lot of developmental edits but that
could be an example where there are
bigger things in the story that they
want you to address or change and then
after that you'll go through a line edit
which is where your editor will mark up
your draft line by line with notes and I
always try to think oh this makes the
book a lot better I love having a lot of
eyes on my material so that's a whole
other path and then after line edit so
you go to copy edit and copy edits are
grammar things also tracking you know if
like you know character suddenly changes
names halfway through your book which
really shouldn't happen ideally you
don't have that but you know that kind
of stuff looking at doesn't do things
makes sense
so kind of more of a technical
and then after that the book gets set
into a type set which is what it will
look like on the page and then even then
you can go through it and still make
adjustments and changes but each time
it's less and less and more specific and
more specific so there are a lot of
passes just on the editorial aspect of
getting your book ready for publication
you